et voilà si vous pensiez que la vie
était nulle et que le confinement
c'était la fin des temps pas de panique
voici une nouvelle encore plus folle que
celle du possible nouveau vaccin
voici les visages des 29 candidates
sélectionnées pour participer à miss
france 2000 21 par les grains priori oui
bon on en a peut-être fait un peu trop
c'est le 19 décembre que la prochaine
miss devrait a priori être élu par les
français
a priori car avec le co vide il est
possible que pour la cérémonie en direct
depuis du fou jean castex disent je
crois que possible en tous les cas une
chose est sûre les 29 miss ont été
choisis des mises dont certaines se
démarquent déjà c'est le cas de luan
l'orphelin miss bourgogne qui n'est sans
rappeler une autre miss marine
l'orphelin évidemment c'est sa soeur
chez pasteur ces parts valent cher c'est
son nom sa soeur autres mises qui sur
les réseaux semblent en avoir conquis
quelques uns c'est lara
[Musique]
non pas cette lara là mais lara lourenço
miss ile de france sans oublier miss
nord pas de calais qui comme d'habitude
et dans les grandes favorites du
concours
reste à savoir laquelle remportera
l'adhésion du public est une chose est
sûre notre favorite et restera pour
toujours la mise de notre coeur et pour
l'argent pierre foucault et pensent qu'à
prendre son chef
alors qui est la grande favorite selon
vous alors les favorites des miss à
l'orias miss languedoc roussillon on
numéro 5
je vous le dis voilà on a rien à faire
qu'on a vu nefic été le plus suivi sur
un stade c'est miss languedoc roussillon
mais belle avec 14000 200 abonnés alors
c'est pas mon délire n'allez pas nous on
va pas se mentir là j'adore les la
coiffure comme ça j'adore mois fait très
belle j'adore mes mais ne mettez pas
tout de suite mais cette fois que celui
des demandes darwich pareil
oui il ya quelque chose que je comprends
pas parce que les miss en nous les
présente souvent avec mais ces fameuses
couronne s'est échappé tout bouge tant
que ça les met pas en valeur et la femme
aujourd'hui elle est moderne action ben
bella sur leur instagram pérou selon les
saisons la cour voit la dernière fois
j'ai fait la galette des rois
mais moi j'ai trouvé beaucoup plus jolie
au naturel les femmes il faut le
moderniser aujourd'hui et je les trouve
très belle soie instagram et je pense
qu'il faudrait mettre alors souvent
comme ça on numéros aux numéros cateau
la maman mamie miss côte d'azur
s'ils vivent encore méfiants et vidéos
elle est magnifique
alors elle s'appelle elle s'appellera
gauthier c'est lara gut y est ça que
ferrero 6-1
non mais je le sais j'ai tout j'ai pigé
le film hollywood la première fois qu'il
pense au temps c'est pas bon venir
mais qui adore les scieries le niveau
cette année très haut je trouve ça en
échange de votre slip oui me permettre
ou dre aurait pu postuler
bien sûr j'aimerais d'ailleurs j'ai déjà
été miss france prévu d'insérer normal
qu'autant banon avait déjà été
minutieusement j'aurais pas pu non en
tant que mannequin on peut pas être miss
france si on fait des photos un peu sexy
et tout ça mais problème je le vrai
problème que vous tapez pour mister
france 17 heures tunisie mr durban dans
l'hesdinois s'est déjà fait des photos
un petit peu olé olé en 3d position hop
hop hop hop hop miss réunion à millions
à widnes aboyer mais là je dis oui elle
gèle à l'univers de la photo il est sa
photo la pauvre elle devait être dans
une tenace de regarder comme ça mon
frère a le truc qu'il doterait mal opté
comme mon frère était mannequin mais
très belle très belle photo matt rodin
aimait aller c'est votre troisième
ouais dix-huit mille abonnés 1 sur un
store numéro 2 ah oui à la je dis oui
nord pas de calais annonce pas de calais
sur favori moi c'est ma favorite
c'est vrai que mr et attaquer les aléas
des taches de rousseur ça revient très
fort l'état joue en fait sur cette photo
elle allait et faria déjà des plus
belles au mieux mais il ya mieux que ça
même photo n'a pas tardé à me faire
chier je vous le dis va pas tarder à me
faire chier je voulais alors est la
grande favorite burundi de cette année
chez les miss c'est miss bourgogne
alors moi oh là là là alors elle
s'appelle luan l'orphelin hills et bien
sûr la seule la soeur de bien entendu
pin ne patrick fiori
c'est bien sûr la soeur de marine
d'orphelins c'est la grandissime favori
en plus en terme de communication en
termes de chlore et ligne c'est à dire
que c'est la soeur est encore miss
france mais des fois cette famille elle
est où
sur ma vie c'est quoi cette famille là
bas et on nous évoque les regards des
questions que je pose à l'esthète que
vous êtes un bruit c'est pas votre cas
mon délire là je parle vraiment voilà à
la seule à l'avoir garoua les baulchois
l'amour de la beauté l'amour au-delà sur
ces cinq jeunes femmes que nous venons
de voir votre top 1 2 3 ça serait alors
quels jeux vous le dire et c'est
complètement désintéressé c'est à dire
numéro 3
je vous le dis je mets jeu mais miss
réunion comme moi j'aime bien numéro 2
je me miss languedoc roussillon et
numéro une année de miss côte d'azur
ah ah oui parce que j'avais en plus moi
je suis un amoureux de la côte d'azur
j'aime toutes les côtes et amenés côte
d'azur j'aime les côtes de boeuf qui me
touche c'est vrai donc voila voila c'est
vrai mais contrairement à l'or j'en ai
d'autres j'en ai d'autres parce que je
me montre ses miss alsace à miss alsace
il paraît que aurait dix roues c'est la
philosophie en fait plus écoutés mais
regarde le pire c'est qu'on cherche à
regarder alors il ya miss auvergne aussi
c'est jérôme il ne s'appelle jéromine
regard des géants me paraît que ella
ella son petit succès je voulais vous
montrer aussi parce que moi une région
que j'adore en france c'est la bretagne
vous me donnez à palets roue d'or mais
qui dit n'importe quoi yes et julie
foricher regarder elle a quelques bons
amis français magnifique
après je gagne ou non miss provence miss
provence on l'a appris les détails ou 90
magnifique oui mr à elle s'appelle
comment monsieur sas et april benayoun
c'est lars email
du rabbin l'été sur de l'écouté c'est
l'avis du taf et la bar mitzvah du petit
shorty et café la circoncision du québec
chétrite ya deux semaines goûtez moi
c'est une beauté sur la tête des gosses
on l'a vu on a pleuré
alors et j'aimerais bien qu'on voit miss
réunion
oui c'est important céline aboyer
regardez alors j'aime bien c'est pas mon
idée mais il est bien allé parce que
j'adore dire le nom en ile de france
l'ile-de-france j'adore c'est ma région
bah oui bel et bien mais c'est la rage
entre non menacées coordonnées solide de
france
je suis en patrouille dans son art alors
en solo merci lé nom de tout le monde
aimait j'ai beaucoup aimé travailler sur
ce dossier
j'aimerais qu'on termine comme
d'habitude bien celui-là 10 et futuna à
un oui j'adore voilà et ouais ouais et
on va terminer par miss rhône-alpes
aussi parce que honda allait souvent ils
eurent merci voilà merci on a là istres
ou bonsoir merci car ronaldo bas rhône
alpes région
ça tient merci nana et les gros niveau
cette année 19 décembre si tout va bien